hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to don't escape now I
absolutely loved script welders deep
sleep series it was really awesome a lot
of fun and I enjoyed it so much that I
had to check out his other game so is
this one called
don't escape which actually sounds
interesting but it's highly rated so I'm
ready to go I believe it's another
point-and-click style adventure game
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I didn't read
that hang on I got to go back hang on
everybody
how do your pantaloons and we're back I
woke up in the room the room is not
locked and I remember everything I'm a
werewolf tonight I will turn and people
will die oh I get it
unless I find a way to prevent myself
from leaving this place I must make sure
that whatever happens I don't escape I'm
a genius because I get the name of the
never mind I'm ready to do it oh good
you can see my face drop and I'm going
to use it on yourself window does finish
game when ready oh wait oh okay no I'm
not ready no no no no no no okay okay so
I have to make sure that I literally do
not escape this game that's so cool wait
a minute that looks familiar
wait a min was that wasn't a what was
that glass bottle my journal the hunt
looks abandoned I'll stay here for a
while and figure out what to do I hope I
haven't eaten whoever lived here tonight
there's a full moon good no good to know
about me for me the broom I don't need
this fireplace is empty pot is filled
with cold water if I could heat it up
for some reason I could shoot myself in
the face and I don't think I want to do
that candle okay so I gotta find things
to apparently make myself not a skip
that's so cool
it's so counter to what everyone
normally would think when you do in a
game okay don't know what that keys to
ah bad okay so what about that okay
found a dried herb there's a lot of
things relating to the deep sleep series
I remember these I have a key to that
doesn't fit in there okay never mind
screw me solid-looking table barrels
seem empty and no use to me so can I go
outside can God's Oh max a bit rusty but
sharp okay so if I put the fire wood in
the fireplace what is that oh it was a
chain under the roof why was there a
chain under the roof of all places why
would be there be a bad and everybody
you know what I don't even so I could
push it but it's blocked so did I get
everything oh I get it now
I wouldn't really stop me if I could
push it in place on the human why would
it push me Wow dad whatever okay so here
we go so yeah I should probably close
that but I can't see anything company
leave that open for now we'll put
firewood in the fireplace
I'm gonna light it on fire with my mind
[Music]
there we go nice and warm so the water's
boiling what if I put the urban the
urban the pot boiling but something's
missing essence of me how about essence
of broom-handle
essence of ass bag it's empty cobwebs
cobwebs cobwebs cobwebs some Oh to the
bed new I gotta get in there how do I
get in there massive okay how do I do
with the axe gotta be some god dang dang
dang ex of myself oh wait but I've
chained my spats not good I don't want
to do that myself wait no that's that's
not what I wanted okay never mind don't
need to do that right now probably later
when things get kinky we go acts crazy
on this whole place I used sons of
[ __ ]
was a 10 device light the candle he
oh I didn't even know that oh I didn't
even know that was a thing oh cool cool
piece of meat and some spices perfect
exactly what I need maybe I don't know I
didn't even know that was a thing how
would anyone have known that okay but I
got things ah put spice in the pot how
awesome meat it's boiling but something
I can't put me oh come on
dang it the meat there let's feed the
beast
grody smashed up the barrel oh come on
smash up the table whoa oh I did it now
ah I see what's doing can I smash up
there oh I lost that Beck's okay okay
heck yeah okay so there anything else
down here that I would need anything is
rule why can't I put myself out there ah
I would never be able to find my way out
it's boiling but it's missing something
silver key maybe no last bottle it's not
ready something missing why what's
missing gotta be something to do with oh
god damn and I looked under that bed I
look like a million times
oh come on oh that is very useful not
really how do I do the potion thingy the
potion I don't cure werewolf postnup
what do you want from me what do you
want from me what do you watch me oh
they're not empty God everything is so
subtle with these things okay I got a
root I got a root put that in there I'm
gonna actually start clearing up so that
I don't forget anything lock the door
close that up put that there
water's boiling potion seems ready take
the potion do that okay bring it over
there put the wood on the thing hammer
the wood up good like any day now
there we go hammer that up good the bed
see gotta be something else I can do
see I got the chain I got the potion and
the key can eat the key yeah eat the key
ain't the key you douche can't move I'm
tired I'm tired okay let's do this yeah
I'm ready
I already feel the urge did something
happening to me I'm ready
[Music]
granny what amazing ones complete oh
wait the weakening potion didn't work at
it well good he bit off the rope that
was restraining him then he struggled
with the chain for a while the meathook
provided distraction but not for long he
ate it fast started ramming the block
door took us some time to break lock oh
come on what oh I killed everybody
oh well is there those who killed your
people partly ety war dad well if his
flame me the woods before a party a
monster off arrived they didn't manage
to drag a beast
oh come on what can i why didn't the
posting work why the pose did not work
maybe I took it too maybe that took it
too late let's try again I'm gonna do
this again hit one of these sticks I
want one of these sticks what is that oh
oh no I can't make the pull shoe work
I'm gonna wait everybody hmm okey
alright that was a mistake that was a
bit of a mistake I may have done wrong I
killed nine people but hey that's you
know yeah whatever
okey
okay so then extra mushroom probably did
it with the al dente whatever you got it
you gotta be a good cook when you do
this do something I don't know tie
myself up and then chain myself and I'm
done right that's it that's all I gotta
do right I'm good
did I miss anything let's hope not yeah
I feel something rising within me waking
potion didn't work at all screw you
screw you this is dumb there's some bull
maybe they deserve to die maybe it was a
good thing maybe that was a village full
of [ __ ] and Nazis and really douchey
people and just they are the worst
like packs would shroom rope root fear
bow would key other key thing about I
don't know oh okay
just as I expected the witch talked in
riddles she said that to weaken the
Beast that would need a handful of hot
dust a crunchy urban something grows in
Earth yet is not a plant that's a shroom
she also mentioned that it would wear
off quite fast so I need to drink a
bright as soon as I do it okay
that is weird crazier shroom and a
handful of hot dissed me broom up some
dust here real quick way to like bonk on
make some dust go fall would spice be a
hot dust I don't know let me try that I
guess put spice in the pot that would be
ready
potions ready okay whatever alright I
guess I guess we're good
that lock it up real good and tight it's
locks okay push that in the way loop
slug it down where's the chain oh god no
rope no chain drank plug and caboose key
feeling a bit dizzy but not much he bit
off the rope that was restraining him
struggled of chain come on started
ramming the blocked window opening it
was easy since what as it wasn't a lot
what it wasn't locked
[Music]
I'm gonna lose my mind terrorizing the
villagers except I'll be naked and with
the clown hat on max would trim trains
rubber boom award Kiki clothes was that
little latch the thing the little
itty-bitty latch I thought I did that oh
come on
the son of a [ __ ] keep hammer fan box
would my mate hot does well cruncher
bless room blasts monk done there lock
clunk pirate okay that that is
definitely locked
[Music]
yes yeah okay I got no sound effects
really
all right transformation complete I'll
just make up the side of myself no
feeling dizzy bit off the rope that was
feigning him struggle his chain meathook
distracted sir ramming the block door -
time to break the lock oh god I'd five
percent didn't kill anyone that was a
miracle is that good is that the only
way to win he considered it one of the
villagers was built God y bydd 1x for
trim paint profile wood RPG in a box
last word BAM twice room oh those budget
that would wear off quite fast do I need
to wait until the end of the night to be
able to take it at the very last second
before I transform is that what I need
to do
oh oh it's not possible hang on wait a
minute wait a minute oh my god I'm
drooling wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute
spice way way way everybody wait wait
wait ah that shroom meet no okay wait no
I knew it I knew it I knew it
oh this actually works that's close up I
think I got it I think I got it I think
I got it oh I think I don't need that
fruit screw the root but nice don't
screw it's cool okay put the meat up oh
my god oh my god did I make sure there
was locked hang on I'm gonna okay rope
and chain the meat is not up why is it
oh god damn it why is the meat not up
why is it meat not up I almost forgot
that okay meat is definitely okay
alright oh my god well Laurie craving
for flesh he bit off the rope that was
from standing him then he struggled with
the chain for a while the meat on the
hook provided distraction but after
eating it it felt very dizzy
so ramming the door took him some time
to break the lock a lot of werewolf was
free wait what what reason who's free
the werewolf broke free from that but it
took much time and ever
we can buy the poisoned tired from
ramming the door he had no strength left
he fled to the woods unnoticed by anyone
oh I did it I did it I did it I did it I
did it I did it I did it I did it okay
yes that took way too long I played this
for like 45 minutes here but anyway I
did it
scrip welder that was a really cool
innovative game not exactly what I was
expecting
took a little while to figure out all
the things but I guess that helped us
people coming back for more but either
way that was a lot of fun scrip welder
has a few more games I may play them
again in the future but for now I'm done
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]